hello everybody so today I want to talk
to you about the Christmas tree we often
hear from neo-pagans and from people who
want to attack Christianity that the
Christmas tree is a pagan ritual and we
hear that not just for the Christmas
tree but all kinds of Christian
traditions of how their origins is
ultimately pagan and for some reason
this is meant to discredit is meant to
show how you know it can't have the
meaning that Christians bring it to so I
thought that we're looking at the
Christmas tree would be a good way to
understand not only the tree itself in
its relation to Christmas but also the
manner in which symbolism happens
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world so like me
you've probably heard several times this
notion that so many of our Christian
traditions including the Christmas tree
has a pagan origin
either that or they'll say that it's
recent that it's not very ancient it
doesn't really matter all of these are
strategies to somehow you know get some
attention for discrediting the Christian
tradition but what's important to
understand if you look at it in the
right way is that the mechanical reasons
why a tradition becomes important
sometimes it matters sometimes there's a
reason why we it's important to track
let's say the historical or let's say
mechanical way in which something comes
into our lives but sometimes it isn't
what's important is rather you can you
know what you can almost see it in a
Darwinian sense so imagine it this way
imagine that the world matter that
people have all these different
variations on how to do things you know
even in terms of the Christmas tree you
know there are all these different types
of Christmas trees they're you know
every Christmas tree is different and
it's the same for all these different
traditions we use to celebrate Christmas
or to celebrate anything that there are
there all these different variations and
possibilities of what can happen now
what's important is not so much that
variation yes that's important but
what's most important is understanding
what is it that selects that is there
are all these different traditions at
pagans had before Christians why is it
that Christianity selected some of these
traditions rather than
others and that's a template for all of
how things work in general that is the
reason why we do certain things what's
important is not so much let's say for
example someone will say you know it's
silly that we clink glasses together
because with that come from in the
Middle Ages they used to do that so that
you know the alcohol would mix together
and if you're trying to poison someone
you know it we'd all poison each other
so it was a way to make sure we're not
poisoning each other and you think you
know and then they'll say what's silly
that we would do that today because you
know look at how dumb you know this the
origin of it is but the reality is is
that they're all there were plenty of
other traditions like that in that time
but for some reason that tradition
survived until now it was selected to
continue on and what and the reason is
because it fits in with a pattern and so
it fits in with the pattern of coming
together it's not it's not very hard to
understand we all are drinking different
things and we bring them all together we
put them together we touch them together
to show that we're in relationship that
we're in communion then we bring them
back to to drink you know it's a it's
like a it's a it's a it's a it's a very
elaborate version of a hug or a kiss
where you you come together with the
person in front of you to show your
solidarity and then you you you go back
on you're on your own
and so what's important is rather to
understand the reason why things are
selected and in that reason that's where
we can see the pattern and in the
Christmas tree what we can see is that
the pattern of the Christmas tree like
so many of the things that I'm trying to
tell you about is basically a
representation it's a it's a
manifestation of the pattern of reality
itself so let's look at the Christmas
tree and and hopefully you'll be able to
to see what I mean when I say that now
like I said there are plenty of
different versions of Christmas tree if
you go on line all you have to do is
write Christmas tree into Google get
thousands and thousands of images of
Christmas trees and they're all
different but they all have something
which makes us recognize that
they are a Christmas tree not one thing
there are several things which come
together into a pattern which help us
recognize that it's a Christmas tree and
not something else okay now what are
those elements first of all there the
fact that the tree itself has to be a
pine tree or a fir or spruce or
something that is that is a conical that
is a triangle okay
other trees won't do so much so most
Christmas trees most of the time they
are the obviously there are always
exceptions but a pattern has exceptions
in its peripheries it will be a kind of
triangle so it's like a pyramid okay and
so already you get start to understand
what it is that this Christmas tree is
about so what's at the top of the
Christmas tree
we put either a star or an angel okay
now a star and an angel actually are
pretty much the same thing even in the
Old Testament for example the word for
star the word for angel and the word for
king for example all are either the same
word or are in the same family of words
because they are principalities they are
the Chiefs the heads that the the
summits of a hierarchy of manifestation
okay for people who are interested in
that you can look at my my video on on
principalities I've done a few to help
you understand how that works so it can
be an actual physical person the king
can act as a principality but a
principality either above the king or
you know there at the top can also be
something which is invisible hidden
hidden and even in the king the fact
that we recognized the king as the
principality of of a country he's hidden
in the king because if he's just another
regular person there's something hidden
which makes him the point of that
hierarchy and the tree itself as a
pyramid becomes the hierarchy itself and
the reason why it's a pyramid is
obviously makes sense
you have one at the top and then it goes
all the way down to many okay that's a
basic idea of a pyramid um in and it can
be it could be a tree or it could be a
mountain I've told you it could be other
things as well but I've showed you in my
video on the symbolism of trees how the
the mountain of paradise with the tree
at the top could be seen as either just
a tree or for example in the story of
Moses could just be seen as just a
mountain going up the mountain and
encountering you know the head of this
whole thing encountering the principle
which holds it all together
and so that's what the angel or the or
the star are at the top of the tree now
around the tree there are these these
these ribbons that go around the tree
and what are these ribbons they're the
same thing as they're that they're the
the periphery of the wheel you could say
they're the turning wheel that goes that
goes around the the hierarchy you could
see it as the snake which goes up the
tree you could see it in other
relationships as for example these are
the ribbons that go around the Maypole
it could just be circumambulation in
general you know circa my religious
circumambulation like a procession which
goes around the city a procession which
goes around the the town and so this is
this coil the snake that goes up the
tree all around it now in the tree
itself we have lights not just lights
but also ornaments and these ornaments
are precious things they're meant to
represent this these precious balls or
these precious objects these golden
objects shiny things that are all into
the tree and so horrified version of
reality we're looking at you know all
the mysteries of reality shown to us in
this Christmas tree because as I've
tried to explain to you before for
something to exist for something to to
to be able to appear on the you know
phenomenological horizon that is that
you suffer some for you to be able to
see that something is real that
something exists
it has to have that hidden spark it has
to have that hidden purpose that hidden
identity which brings it together into
one and so these lights in the tree are
basically an image of how reality lays
itself out and how hidden in the
hierarchy are all these different little
lights these Logie these these these
smaller principalities smaller essences
which are hidden in in manifestation
hidden in the world you know and so you
see the the hierarchy itself as being
full of light the light that comes from
above is now filling up the entire tree
and showing us the the gems in the world
and so then at the bottom of the tree
what do we usually have we put the gifts
now what's important with the gifts is
to understand that the gifts are wrapped
the gifts are hidden and that's really
the most important part because even in
a little bit not that long ago just one
generation ago my father for example at
Christmas they could get either a gift
or they could get just a chunk of coal
and so the idea is you know depending on
if you're good or bad the gift could
either be something positive or negative
but now we've only kept the positive but
we can still understand this idea that
you don't know what's there
it's potentiality its Schrodinger's box
if the cat is could be alive it could be
dead we're looking at the potentiality
of reality it's not it's not revealed
yet okay and then hidden in this
potentiality are the gifts and so the
gifts are just like just like the lights
in the tree for example they are these
hidden precious things which are in
potentiality you know the the treasure
that's hidden in the unknown you can see
that you know the treasure that's
guarded by a dragon or the idea of in
the in the Bible for example we have
Saint Peter who goes to the shore and
finds a golden golden piece in the mouth
of a fish
but also the fish itself which is the
symbol of Christianity early Christians
represents exactly that imagine there's
this water of death is chaotic water and
then in the water you find these
sparkling things these sparkling living
things these things that are useful
inside the chaos so you can fish and you
can you can bring out of this death and
out of this chaos things which are
useful things which are precious and so
that is really this idea of the of the
gifts that at the bottom of the world if
you will and so I know some of you might
doubt that this is what it's referring
to but a good way to understand that
that's exactly that that that is indeed
what what were what we're dealing with
is to remember other traditions of
Christmas once again we're usually do we
hide the gifts we put them under the
tree but there's another place where you
put them right we put them in the socks
put them in the stockings and so at the
bottom of a sock we will hide a precious
thing and in the old times they would
usually hide an orange you know we have
this story of st. Nicholas who hides a
golden ball at the bottom of a sock and
so this golden ball which is hidden at
the bottom of phenomenological reality I
don't I really struggle to imagine a
better way to represent the bottom of
phenomenological reality then the bottom
of a sock because that's where your feet
touch the ground the earth and so and
and once again this idea of putting a
orange or a gift in a sock it used to be
that we would all we could maybe put a
piece of coal there as well to kind of
remind you that you've been naughty and
so that is basically the the kind of
structure now in order to kind of to
understand that the whole thing and how
the gifts are also at the bottom of the
tree or the golden ball is hidden at the
bottom of the sock you also have to
remember that Christmas is the Solstice
and so it is the law that it is when the
Sun is going down so every day that
the the days get shorter and shorter
until the solstice and then at the
Solstice the days start to get longer
and so you can imagine that the day is
going down down down we're going down
into darkness we're descending into
death we're descending into the lowest
place and the question is what's gonna
happen is it just gonna keep going is is
we're just going to be overwhelmed by
darkness but no in that lowest place do
you have this hidden thing you have this
golden ball at the bottom of the the
pond you know the in the story of the
the prince
princess on the Frog yet this golden
ball at the bottom of the pond these
golden ball at the bottom of a sock you
know or the gifts hidden under the tree
hidden in the in being hidden in their
wrappings and so the Sun goes all the
way down and then it starts to to come
back up so you can see that at this time
other traditions have similar feasts as
well the Jews in December celebrate
Hanukkah and so in Hanukkah it's the
same story you have the the Seleucids
we're attacking Israel and you know it's
dire and everything's you know they have
nothing left and then they have this one
last little jar of oil and they you know
they pour the oil into the into a lamp
and miraculously this lamp
you know continues on doesn't doesn't
never goes out and so this idea of this
lamp that doesn't go out in the darkest
time or in the you know in the place
where the Sun is going down is to help
you understand the the way that reality
works in order for you to proceed
anything like I said there has to be a
hidden light the world is never
completely empty of meaning this notion
for example that we find of total
depravity that that the world is
completely lost and that that you know
you know that human beings are
completely fallen and there's nothing
left in them is impossible because if
that were true they've been uh they
wouldn't exist in order for something to
exist there has to be hidden even if
it's completely you know sullied even
even it's completely he
in darkness there has to be a spark just
for things to exist a spark of meaning
okay now alright so we've done all of
this going down and there are other
stories that Christ talks about this
this kind of hidden thing in the you
know that the pearl in the field there
are many images of that as well there's
also the story of Elijah and the widow
it's a very similar story than the one
that you find for example for the the
Maccabean revolt you have this notion of
a time where there's no food you know
and there's a drought and everybody's
dying of hunger
and there's this Widow who who has a
last one last jar of oil and she's like
this is it I'm gonna die and Elijah
tells her to go to the jar of oil and
when she goes the jar of oil never runs
out and so this idea that that the jar
of oil and oil is similar even to fire
because it's a glistening liquid it
reflects you know it's it's like that's
what they use to anoint kings and so
it's like this this kind of light that
comes down and a solid light that comes
down and so the oil is just just doesn't
never completely runs out and you can
see that Elijah also resurrects the son
of a widow and so this resurrection of
the son of the widow and also the oil
that that doesn't run out is the same as
this little light this little flicker at
Hanukkah that doesn't doesn't go out and
it's the same as the Sun which goes down
at the Solstice and then you know starts
to come back out again out of this kind
of secret dark place okay now a lot of
you will a lot of you will will wonder
you know what does this have to do with
Christmas because I haven't gotten to
Christmas yet well there are a few
things the first thing to remember about
the Christmas story is that the
Christmas story is exactly that descent
you have to understand the aspect of the
killing of the innocence is a very
important part of Christmas King Herod
in looking for Christ trying to find
this Messiah started to kill the the
newborns
in Bethlehem so I had to kill the the
newborns and so in this time of death
and this time of ravage where all the
the seeds you know all the lights are
going out there is this one light that
survives this one child which survives
and will then grow to become the new
principality of a new hierarchy of a new
world that will lay itself out a new Sun
that will rise up to its zenith and then
and then rule the rule the the
phenomenological world all right and so
that's part of the good and it's the
same with the story of Moses as well you
know the the Pharaoh decides to kill all
the Hebrew children and so he's killing
all these Hebrew Chim but there's one
child who survives and then he's you
know he's not represented as like let's
say a shining light at the bottom of
water but he's represented as this seed
which floats on the on the on the waters
which is hidden in the seed and floats
on the water so it's the same it's it's
the same symbolism as the others now in
order to kind of cinch all of this for
you last week I put out a video to show
you the symbolism of the Nativity icon
and so let's look at that let's look at
that icon again now look at the icon of
the Nativity what is its major form with
its major shape
it's a mountain and so this mountain is
this pyramid it's this hierarchy you can
see it go up yeah you know the small at
the top large at the base what's at the
top of the mountain a star and angels
okay like I said those two things are
very close to each other in terms of of
their meaning
now now this ray of light goes down it's
coming down from the Principality coming
down from the top and moving down into
what's not the bottom of the tree or the
bottom of the the mountain but rather is
this dark place of death inside the
mountain notice that inside the cave
it's completely black and so it is this
place of total darkness
this plates also of animals this place
of a this low place of death
you know and the the manger is an animal
food trough and it's also represented as
a sarcophagus so it really is this place
of death but in this place of death
that's where we find the seed that's
where we find this spark this this
divine spark which is hidden and will
then grow to become you know the new
principality and so you see it of course
in the story of Christ it is a cosmic it
is the cosmic version of this it is that
it is the version which shows us the the
let's say the the hidden seed of the
entire world that is he is the logos of
all creation the source of all creation
but at smaller levels we can see how
this manifests itself can manifest
itself it at smaller and smaller scales
for it all of reality that's just how
reality works um
and so like I said like I've told you
other times before you know you it's
it's it's that something that we
encounter all the times we imagined once
again a fruit that drops from the tree
starts to decompose starts to treat to
become death itself and and to become
just dirt but hidden in that process
there's that seed that's there and you
can't see it at first because it's a
it's a it's a baby it's a it's a two
seed without body it's this spark and
then slowly the process inverts itself
and the seed begins to feed on the
potentiality feed on the earth and grow
so that you see this new plant come up
just like the switch of the Sun at the
end of the solstice is invisible you
can't see it you don't realize at first
that the days are going getting longer
and then they start to to grow grow grow
and like I've told you before that's why
we have theophany you know at the end of
the Christmas cycle to kind of it's like
this realization that yes the Sun you
know this this hidden emmanuel this God
in us God with us is now showing itself
it's starting to appear in in the world
just like the days are getting longer in
the year as well so I hope that brings
get kind of all together for you and
helps you understand especially like I
said that it doesn't often it doesn't
matter what the mechanical
cause the you know historical or pseudo
historical origins of something is
what's important is the fact that it has
been selected it has been retained and
it comes together and participates in
the the message or the let's say the
reality that we inhabit it doesn't mean
that some of these things don't get
pruned off or come back come join
themselves and get pruned off again
that's fine especially in these less
important things like a Christmas tree
obviously is not like the the creed or
like you know the crucifix it's a it's a
peripheral tradition but you can still
show us just how it continues to
participate in this symbolic process so
first of all I had promised you a video
and ghrelin then it is coming but I just
wanted to do this because I've been
thinking about it and I thought you
would find it interesting to to hear
about this subject today I think it's
playing I'm recording this at 12 so I
think it's playing live now you can
check it out when I put out the video a
tear of the dawn who is the official
musician DJ of the intellectual dark web
I guess he he's putting out a Christmas
album today and it's he told me that I
am going to be one of the people quoted
in his meaning wave Christmas and so
he's going to take clips from my Santa
video and put them inside this big mix
and I'm really excited to hear what he
comes up with and a little bit scared at
the same time because I saw that he's
got me out there with Alan Watts and
jakka willings and of course
Jordan Peterson and so it'll be exciting
to to discover what exactly how exactly
is going to fit me into all of this
stuff so so that's happening and also I
told you once before that I'm working on
a graphic novel with my brother Matt's
here and also cord Nielsen who is an
artist so we started putting out
promotional art or you know on the
graphic novel we finished thumbnailing
the first book and so we're gonna start
to we want to thumbnail the whole story
which is going to be like four parts
probably but we finished thumbnailing
the first book we're gonna start to do
some actual drawing and and so cord made
a really cool poster that will help you
kind of understand i'll let you follow
me on social media to get the details of
that
but let you see what let you discover
what the subject of our graphic novel is
going to be so so I'll see you soon guys
and thanks for your support
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your insights and questions
in the comments section you can also
share this video on social media to your
friends and as you can please consider
supporting us financially through
patreon or PayPal you'll find those
links in the description below